[Music]
thank you
back to back
yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys
as you can see king is not here
currently that doesn't mean he's not
coming uh he told me he's coming in hot
uh so you know you guys know what that
means he he'll be here probably in the
next 10 minutes but anyway
we got a lot to talk about today man
dirt the amount of salt we are about to
what's what I'm looking for the amount
of salt that we're about to manifest
into the world is going to be legendary
people in the chat I know I know most
the time you know we we very we very
PlayStation Fanboy friendly
King and dirt are going to be in the
same podcast it's going to be like the
Ultron whatever it is when they combine
forces to make the ultimate bean I don't
know if you guys want to be there today
imma be real
so there's a back door you know we we
have at the Shameless entrance you know
the media is not out there so
PlayStation Fanboys take that back door
because I don't know if you want to sit
around for this Slaughter
but if you guys want to
then uh I guess I guess we'll get on
with the show you know we kind of just
did a spoiler alert for PlayStation
fanboys
same with this yeah man give him a
disclaimer man let him know
but anyway
thank you guys for coming to the ad show
we talk about the past present future
gaming I got my coach with me dirt
griggity what's going on dirt
what's up man you know I see somebody in
the chat already saying that Bobby kotec
killed the deal shut up
get out of here man that's that's what I
see in a few PlayStation Fanboys trying
to run with today I had somebody tag me
they dirt are you gonna talk about Bobby
what did Bobby kotec say what did he say
to make you guys think he's going to
kill that that he killed the deal y'all
this is hoping and wishing y'all can get
anything positive because the past few
uh days of this y'all y'all been silent
and say some things but he didn't really
say anything to hurt Microsoft case in
my opinion he said some things out he's
been true but not y'all yeah yeah might
be cool thanks shut up
I'm sorry you're fine King will be here
guys okay he he he he out there on he
fighting the Twitter when you're on the
front line
sometimes it takes some news oh look
here's one of the posters
it's it's it's a Grace's poster right
she got one for her daughter
could you could you do my two
Wednesday
that's all you guys are going to see the
rest of the podcast that's all you're
gonna see what's up guys
see see look look this is this is kind
of what I felt like that's kind of what
I felt like the lawyers
to Microsoft was wearing that day they
sitting there with the pose like this
they know what they doing they they know
gotta find out super trap from the angry
therapist shout out to dirt addict y'all
about to form Blazing Sword blazing
swords man
yeah let's go Baby I'ma check on King we
hold up hold up actually you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna call King
live on the show
all right
let me make sure I don't like bomb his
number
yeah we we live right now I'm calling
you live on the show
he's almost here guys
can you hear him yeah yeah I know it's
them you they can't hear you all right
we'll see you when you get here me and
Dirk just gonna play around till you get
here
okay yeah I will say though you know
when you when your dinner on the front
line we expect you to be on time
here
we hear [__]
all right all right
all right so
there's been a lot going on man you know
we'll go ahead and because I feel man I
feel like everything here Keen to be
part of when you've been playing dirt
we're going we're gonna we're gonna try
to to have as much time go by Jax with
the two on super trap piece of the week
is going in there
I do want to jack a sway from your
podcast though I've been thinking about
it for a while I want to Jack that
Metacritic score thing because I think
that's fun yeah yeah yeah this one yeah
this one I got I need your permission
before I snatch that [__] it's fun man
yeah of course all right so what you've
been playing man
actually
um I went back to a couple of games
that was on my uh backlog got them
Knights and cyberpunk I'd be kind of
messing around with those two games
you know because I still haven't
finished Starlight Jedi survived I'm
Star Wars Jedi Survivor
uh you know I was trying to finish the
Street Fighter world tour or not you
know there's so many games to play but
but for some reason I wanted to finish
because I believe I'm like halfway
through Gotham nice I want to finish
that and also cyberpunk so
yeah so I've been playing there's been a
couple of things I've been playing
I've been playing a lot of Final Fantasy
16. uh it is is a great game but uh you
know I know people it's not the the
input it's not a good Final Fantasy game
you know it it kind of like how it felt
like breath of the wild and Fallout 4 I
think I said on IOP great game even
maybe a game of the year could tender
but it's not a good Final Fantasy game
you know when you compare to its
predecessors predecessors it falls short
all right so having heard you get into
it with uh you know like with a pony on
Persona yeah
how did you hear about that like do you
know how to say names somebody told me
oh man
um
somebody mentioned oh no no somebody put
it on Twitter
like yo man they uh like had to get into
it with Persona over Final Fantasy 16.
why the show was live so then I went and
checked it out yeah watch out let don't
let him step on that
yeah I think when it comes down to it
look I actually respect Persona and
Jabari as as content creators I don't
like their opinions half the time
but they are one of the few people that
you look at the what's up PlayStation
they do generally keep that PlayStation
orientated they don't spend three hours
talking about what Xbox didn't do or
what Xbox did do or spend the net it's
been the same three hours every week
talking about it jabari's what's up
Podcast is a legit PlayStation podcast
and I will recommend it because they do
keep it to the now obviously Jabari and
Persona they they play station Fanboys
yo yeah I'm a little Fanboy sometimes
but
that particular podcast I have respect
for them because they kind of put that
to the side you know and if you really
think about it besides like big podcasts
like stuff for IGN or something like
that there's no other PlayStation
podcast like that yeah can you hear
people talking in the background yeah
you can hear it
yeah I don't have a problem with those
guys because you know I mean like you
know the only problem I have with the
only points that have problems with I
once is always talking [__] to me
yeah and that's why you know regardless
how people feel about you know persona
I we we go back and forth but there's no
real beef there you know there's people
I legitly can't stand yeah but Persona
and Jabari aren't one of them yeah it's
just a back and forth thing you know and
what I do respect is regardless if I
disagree with his opinion on how what
was going down with the Final Fantasy 16
I respect him knowing he knows what he's
talking about Final Fantasy there's a
lot of people that love to come at me
sideways that have never really played
Final Fantasy like that
hmm
man king where are you
where are you we're gonna start with the
Xbox fighting for exclusive games King
will be here eventually it's just you
know we we uh he he taking his time man
you know sometimes the you know how like
the general comes in the back you know
he comes to the back and King right now
is like is like the Lord of the Rings
thing well we're sitting there and
they're on the top of the hill and we're
like our stronghold's about to get
destroyed all hope looks lost and King
shows up on the horse going back and
forth it was like today is where we
stand
he's just going back with the the sword
hitting all the the spears back and
forth
right it's uh two dollars from a dollar
night smoking on a Sony pack did I miss
any super chats besides that no it
doesn't
um no so uh let's talk about
let's talk about this first topic so we
we got um a topic
Indiana Jones and it looks like project
Dragon whatever is The Islander active
has been deemed in XBox exclusive now
keep in mind we don't know if these are
like guaranteed or not you know these
could be old information but I would
willing to guarantee you that these
these racket you know yeah so I mean
well hell well the Indiana Jones P Hines
said that under oath uh a couple days
ago so that's current information yeah
well no I'm talking mainly about the
project dragon from uh okay okay fair
enough it does look like that is a a
place an XBox exclusive so I thought you
know this this conversation we can
finally get going and we're you know it
was funny as I said we weren't going I
wasn't going to do timestamps today and
I'm already doing time stamps
angry therapist King putting on the
General's outfit oh he's probably not
going to do anything like that oh it's
just it's the first one hold up let me
show everyone oh thank you babe that
looks good look at this
I can't see it back it up a little bit
there we go there we go
it's me
Mario I like this and what's funny is
they sell these things do you because
it's like I said I'm tired of the only
fans background that people claim I have
so you're gonna see those in here now I
have another one I just don't know where
it's at but all right so with all that
going on we're seeing more and more
games coming as an XBox exclusive
do you think that they did hear us when
they said we want more original content
that mainly is only on Xbox
absolutely man and you know what's so
crazy with you like when you're hearing
some of the behind the scenes stuff that
Xbox had to do with Bethesda man that
stuff is crazy how PlayStation was out
here buying these exclusives and you
know what fair enough that's business
you know it is what it is
but for Xbox to even compete with that
they had to buy the whole damn company
man they had to buy the whole company
PlayStation was trying to you know that
they made deaf Loop exclusive they made
ghostwide Tokyo exclusive and they were
trying to make Starfield exclusive now
we heard that rumor before but we got
official confirmation that PlayStation
was trying to make that game exclusive
so Xbox had to do what they had to do
just like when Phil Spencer said um with
Indiana Jones he wanted the fans Us Xbox
fans to to have an exclusive game
outside of gaming meaning a movie
franchise kind of highlights Sony has
Spider-Man that's why they made the deal
to make Indiana Jones exclusive so yeah
man Xbox no they need exclusives we
wanted big exclusives like you know
Spider-Man but you know it's obviously
not a superhero but Indiana Jones is
still a pretty big IP so you know with
some good stuff man
yo mute
I do think that Microsoft is showing
that you know we're working on this you
know
you could definitely argue that
Microsoft's first party output's been
you know very lackluster the past couple
years even in 2021 that was a great year
for Microsoft but in terms of exclusive
content it was still lacking because
everything was multi-plat the reason
that it was so good for them as a
publisher is because even though it was
multiplied they were making quality
games that year you know with waistline
3 death Loop they've really pushed
forward with that the majority of their
games were 85 and above that year yeah
yeah it was and like Psychonauts and
Halo and Forza yeah they had some
quality stuff there yeah first off shout
out to over 350 people in the chat and
King ain't even here yet man
you know King ain't even here you guys
are in the hit that like button guys
likes up let's get those likes up before
I lock General King behind the paywall
that you know what's funny I'm doing
this new thing on IOP where I'm pretty
much like forbidding King to do his
personalities until we get a certain
amount of likes
it's working it's working phenomenal
though like it really is like and it's
it's like a little joke thing you know
it what's funny oh here we go
someone has joined the building
I'm so sorry guys I do apologize no you
don't gotta apologize we know we know
the the amount of work it takes to to
run the front lines is not it takes a
while we know that so what's going on
I'm swimming and I had to swim over here
in Sony test
was it you didn't drowned did you
because it was like no no it's pretty
deep wasn't it yeah it was it was up to
my neck Paul and um
he's just doing backstrokes up to sodas
being that I'm chunky I got a good
buoyancy you heard
attic I love those headphones
um oh oh you know how like they always
be making fun of my quote-unquote only
fans background yeah what you doing I
went and got these
this is one of them
peaches peaches peaches I have another
one but it's not in there yet see we
play nice with Nintendo because Nintendo
don't play it nice with y'all
so what I was thinking is I'll I'll buy
them throughout and I'll just replace
them like I'll put these in like the
closet and yo I got a Halo one that I
can send you that's dope
I got a I got a lot I got Jaws I got a
lot of them I haven't put them up
because
um I don't have space yeah see but you
don't really you know it's funny if you
took everything out of Kings he would he
looked more like an only fans calves
than I would like the white walk but
when you got all the statues it helps
man it definitely helps this would
really look like an only Fan's basement
like
yeah
so well you know we signed out of work
ponies
um oh
cause y'all gonna be on a job in a
second baby
hey man they gotta have something to do
don't they oh man well listen we're
gonna put them to work man
we got contracts we got um 10-year
contracts we're having them signed oh
man
[Laughter]
this Maximus really expenses hand in our
10-year contracts for all ponies
[Music]
yeah you imagine
if people
got his Petty is like if if like a
corporation like Microsoft did J dub
stuff on Twitter like the pony contract
and stuff where they're literally
handing out bags to go to to do nothing
Michelle
that would be funny if these dudes
wasn't as sensitive as they are right
now you know because remember back in
the days you know that those commercials
was really you know uh a little racy
like uh Sony's commercials yeah yeah
especially that PS3 yeah yeah they were
they were out there you know and and I
missed those days you know Nintendo
those things is now we're forced to play
nice you know now everybody get a
participation trophy no yeah I know
exactly where you were in the pecking
order bro [__] aggressive or lies you
know um you know if you're second or
third we had a console Market where we
supported
um what was it four or five different
consoles at one time you remember that
Game Gear was a separate console uh Game
Boy was a separate console yeah turbo
Graphics you had on Nintendo the Genesis
yeah and you had Sega and then you had
Neo Geo the high-end uh uh drinks you
had a 3DO he had always at the market at
one time
and Atari Jaguar yeah you know we had
all these at the market yeah some dudes
fell off but it was a competition it was
real competition you don't remember
going out and getting the same uh video
game on multiple platforms and whoever
had the best one they just won like
Nintendo
um had the best sound with that Street
Fighter the graphics crunchy remember
Mortal Kombat 2. yeah Genesis version
was cool but then I played the Super
Nintendo version Oh that version is way
better bro the Super Nintendo version
was way better but the sweat though no
no that's that's part one that's part
one give me all your parts
look what I'm uh uh what you got what
you got going on
oh oh you saw my drink uh
you saw you saw me when I posted my dog
my dog was up there I did a patreon
um for x-cast
and um that my dog is up there because
my dog you know get down in the basement
she's she's sniffing my ankle like what
you doing Daddy and I'm like oh I'm on
the show yeah I uh we're watching my uh
sister's dog all right
let me ask you a question has that dog
showed you that pettiness yet no are you
talking about because it's a husky yeah
Huskies or the pet I haven't really got
pettiness from this husky yet but I know
what you're talking about it exists they
definitely exist they do they take a
poop in your sneaker and all that yeah
they kind of crazy yeah they outside
with it yes so King
you know we got the first off I want to
explain to you what I say dirt is in the
community I say because you know how
Dirt he he's very uh you know he he
spawns off you know we we are safe space
for Xbox people you know he he he laughs
he's like we got this Echo tape we're
going on I was like I was like this is
what's happened okay king and iops the
front lie we should we we got the the
the shields up the spears I was like I
was like dirt he's in the second line he
got the The Archers the dirts dirt's
going in front of us it is like there's
going in front of us and he's like
release the arrows
yeah I definitely watch his show and I
definitely get the I'ma tell you man
I gotta give you your flowers now
because you know uh even though we have
each other's contact and all that other
stuff
brother what what Lane you've carved out
for yourself and the uh level of success
that you're having it's beautiful to see
thank you brother beautiful to see
because it's all you it's all your own
like yeah
um you're not being anybody else you
being you and it's authentic and it's
great to see because you say a lot of
stuff that I wish I could say yeah
I just got to be creative with her but
um yeah POS I love that that's why
that's why I'm always like at the end of
the show I'm like dude don't just put
your stuff in there once I want you to
spam that chat they gotta know where you
are Yeah man they gotta see it I see his
chat 500 strong 600 strong my man Rock
and I just go in there put the thumbs up
like I'll listen to it later my man
doing this thing thanks man I appreciate
you guys man
Panic is boss that's a that's a crazy
name hopefully our uh the RS brings us a
bigger tax return after the FTC has been
wasting our money for the past 18 years
you're about to get those savings is not
going to be passed upon you all right so
what we were talking about when you
popped in is uh we're talking about
Xbox seems to have been like way more
aggressive in the in the PlayStation
exclusive content stuff uh with Indiana
Jones it's it's stuff being redone uh
it's still being redone and we're seeing
you know project Dragon I'll interact
and confirmed an XBox exclusive of what
it looks like uh what what is your
opinion on that do you think that that's
definitely one of the things Microsoft
is going towards
yeah yeah things get still things feel
nice
tell them yeah yeah I still think he
missed a nice guy he want to come y'all
like Kumbaya stuff that y'all was
kicking around and kicking a can down
the street he ain't no dominance he
ain't no Maximus he really is he kicking
the can down the street y'all see the
facts in the paperwork oh boy sick and
tired of being sick and tired you ain't
gonna smack somebody for so long for for
them to turn around and say you know
what all right you want to play with
dirty we gonna play dirty and that's why
he tell you hold on wait a second that's
what I'm telling you the whole line
because I already know I already know
what old boy have cooking I already know
certain stuff that was cooking so when
y'all surprise like oh he's doing that
yeah he's doing that he's trying to do
worse because you're my cup King turn my
mic up that's what the chat yeah I got
to mess it up a little bit right now in
general but keep talking about I got you
I got you hold on we don't want to miss
a word there we go that's that's good
right there okay let me know if it's
better Chad put a one in the chat if
it's better let me know get this mic
right here you don't want me to talk
Barry White style into the mic yo
um is
yet that this dude is trying to win he
don't even like to be compared to his
contemporaries he doesn't like to be
compared to Peter Moore because
everybody sits there and say oh the 360
is the best um
the best ERA of Xbox he said I beg to
death would be I beg to differ um right
now we got more popping we got more
subscribers we got more people going on
and we making more Revenue right don't
overlook what I'm doing and then give me
my flowers when I'm gone don't know give
it to me now on the face of Mount
Rushmore be I'm the face and in is that
competitive nature that I saw in him in
order for me to back the dude in this
manner I know he's gonna do what he got
to do by hooker crookby he's trying to
win
um
yo there one of the joints was like I
want to buy Sony like yeah
I said I said do what I'm talking about
he want to go in the building I told you
before he won't buy him and throw
everybody out get out
I told you so y'all be acting like this
energy that I have is energy that is
misplaced so can you back in the wrong
horse you know I'm back in the right
horse because that horse got cash and
let you slip up once you're gonna slide
right here don't remember Bobby was
acting a fool before that Bobby came in
there with a I got an offer you can't
refuse type of thing he had to Thug and
Debo my dude my dude was like all right
all that stuff came out the stock start
Plumbing
guess who's back right guess who's back
yeah and animal put an offer you can't
refuse and and from what we see Bobby is
All About The Bread probably don't want
no Game Pass Bobby don't want none of
that Bobby want a nickel and dime to
Consumer as much as he possibly can he
thinks Game Pass is not conducive to
making any real inroads in cash that's
all Bobby care about don't care about
nothing else
Phil knows that use that against him and
Bobby said no I would have never sold to
them but the boy I'm beholding to the
board no Bobby the truth of the matter
is you did a lot of egregious things
under your watch you were being kicked
out Bobby and they wanted to have a
better face the better faces Phil the
same face you disrespected the same face
that you said now we're gonna charge you
more the same face for the same Brick
we're gonna charge you more why because
we can why because you need us well
Bobby you need us now
so you take the stand and you do what
you got to do you do what you got to do
and you get this over the line so we can
do what we got to do and you're gonna
take that little golden parachute and
get the hell up out of here and that's
what happens this is how Cutthroat my
man is when it comes to situation when
it comes to doing these deals so you're
gonna see a lot more that he want to buy
Square yeah it's sick and tired of being
sick and tired y'all sort of rides y'all
made him bad he's he that he's Fed Up of
it he's fed up with this mess bro what
happens when a rich dude is fed up he
bought a house next to you and kick you
out yeah
that dude man yeah man I'm about all of
this this is so much fun okay well like
the whole story about you know with with
deaf loot that's why Tokyo Phil said
hold on hold on wait a minute y'all
trying to Yo okay y'all got those games
as timed exclusives now y'all trying to
get this game start feel feel new star
Fields is going to be special right
people say hold on wait a wait a minute
now y'all y'all are already the market
leader now y'all are taking games away
from us big big games okay you know what
we're just gonna buy the company I'm
tired of this foolishness yeah I'm tired
of y'all playing this game no we're
going to buy the company and and Phil
admitted that because of them being
third place sometimes it's you know it's
more expensive to get a Time exclusive
because some of the companies don't want
to do it because they're the third third
place so first I just buy the whole
company because it turns into oh we
become the face of your company like yup
your brand represents our brand if your
brand is in third place then we'll
representing third praise right know
um what the cache that comes with being
in first place
people really don't understand
like you get tax breaks
get leniency in certain things because
they know that your product is going to
sell or they assume that your product is
going to sell over there right if if
they say oh we're we're backing a a
failing horse
then that doesn't lead to good deal good
negotiation right because you're coming
in from a position of weakness this is
business this is capitalism
you you have to understand if you're not
first then you definitely last and when
you last you got to take what you can
take
what they're trying to do like you know
packed I gotta I got a shout out Michael
pacta because I've been ringing this
Bell for a long time but he actually
said that set it on um on Destin show
Microsoft doesn't care about the point
of sale
they want to grow Game Pass from 25
million to 250 million because that's
where the money is you see Jim realizes
that as well that's why he told y'all
wasn't enough y'all don't understand
business
you're not enough this is the reason why
he's going to games of a service that
business model lends to what he wants to
do if you look at the the paperwork the
paperwork even says it he wants to
monetize
the existent fan base to the extent that
he can make triple what he's making now
right so he wants to give you games that
have uh season passes he wants to give
you games that have DLC he wants to give
you games that's why I told y'all when
God of War when I told you God of War
was one complete game and he split it
into two on purpose um dude just like no
no he didn't dude it's the same damn
assets you know I saw um Asgard there
I'm not able to get to ask God why is
that didn't you don't see when you're
sending out a complete Game you won't
have incomplete uh things there you will
have a complete story because uh game
Publishers and and game developers don't
know if the project will continue so
let's finish it right and finish a
complete project they don't leave you on
a cliffhanger
when you leaving somebody on a
cliffhanger that means that you knew it
was going to be this and you cut it off
here you slid that out the door because
you because you was gonna sell it to him
again so what he did was take a seventy
dollar project and sold it to you for
140. we got that money and then whatever
other stuff that you brought that was
there or whatever you did that so you
can't fault the man Phil for his
business acronym but you gotta fault
them in for having a service and telling
you he don't believe in services so
you'll never see day in day shout out to
Matt booty for doing what he do you know
everybody wanted me to give Matt a name
how did you feel about Matt
standing up and bucking up against Phil
and everybody else with day and date
inside Game Pass and you're gonna stay
the course we're not going back you're
going to stick the course on this Matt
stood up because everybody thinks Matt
is quiet and meek but Matt stood up and
stood up for us so how did you feel
about that Dirk I felt that uh before
like first let me say this when people
are in these positions like a matte
moody or Phil Spencer they can't be a
soft right you know people depend on
them they have to give direction so
sometimes I think people want I don't
know what people expect feel expensive
or mad booty they do go up there smack
somebody or something no no that's not
gonna happen but these guys are not
timid they're not soft they're they're
the authority figures at a huge company
one of the top three companies in the
world
um but back to what you said I
appreciate mad booty doing that say no
we get we made this decision let's stay
on it no no there's no going back
there's no flip-flopping
we can handle it you know what I'm
saying uh and and he also knows that
game pass day and day is for me
personally I can't speak for everybody
else but that's one of the biggest
reasons it's the best service in the
world of me you know as far as gaming
bruh these games are dropping day one in
there so yeah I appreciate Matt booty
saying that instead of no understanding
on this too say yo this is what we're
gonna do yeah because it wouldn't change
it from being what PlayStation premium
is you know it would right it would be
the same thing yeah right and what what
new are you bringing to the table that
changes the dynamic right and it also
shows and because I would really would
love to see the metrics that games do so
I I um I saw people posting they got the
consolation Edition for Starfield and
and all that other stuff that goes along
with it me personally you have to prove
yourself to me I mean I have to play
your game and I'll be like you know what
I'm giving that bucks I'm gonna pay for
it you know um because me being in the
service is pay payment enough me making
that commitment that oh I'm gonna have a
year subscription that's payment enough
then these the games do come in and then
sometimes when I see games leaving and I
say you know what nah let me buy that
they got me with that who's the stuff
because I thought when they're not
coming back I was like oh yeah it came
right back
people gotta realize
that and I know y'all love your your
plastic box uh shout out to you ponies
that love your plastic box you love it I
I'm not really a fan of the plastic box
itself right I want revenge I don't care
what anybody said y'all can take it how
you want to take it I'm just picking the
biggest bully in the park the one that
y'all would thought is stupid yeah okay
I just picked the biggest bully that I
know that can get you up out of there
because I know exactly who you are you
formidable I'm not saying that you're
not but you're not the same you got a
little fat you got a little old your jab
ain't looking the same your right hand
slipping your footwork ain't good and
you're still arrogant like you're young
but you're not that dude no more right
right and just do young and hungry I
understand exactly what's gonna happen
here so I'm back in that dude but I got
everybody I just choose the the game
here because I think the ecosystem is a
little bit better
you guys got to really understand this
is the time when you're supposed to
fight now
you PlayStation dudes gotta see all that
stuff that Jim is saying it don't build
bold well for you
as a consumer you can't keep telling me
that yeah we buy our games here that is
nothing to Puff your chest out about
nothing at all all right because back in
the days we would go to the arcades with
a string on our finger with a quarter
with a hole with a hole in it
and I'll be in there going
oh wow I have 500 credits inside Miss
Pac-Man I'm saying I never thought of
that before we did that we had slugs we
did everything game as well cheap by
Nature right we wanted that's why you
think we emulate why we do these things
because we're cheap by Nature so don't
tell me that you sticking out your chest
that you brought a game you're doing
that because you have no other recourse
say that part but hold their feet to the
fire demand day in day demands the
service that you paid for to be of value
because a lot of dudes use it as oh
that's extra I got that that's there no
demand better
right
yeah yeah I hear yeah I feel the same
way I don't know what's going on with
YouTube it keeps for saying it's not
receiving enough it will it will
straighten out here in a second you know
we're gonna go and move on to the amount
of Studios that Xbox is trying to buy or
have bought is absolutely insane and I
want to hear from you King about the
list we're gonna call it the list and
what you feel about it
I I always knew that he would do that
like he would do Scorch turf you know um
he was really pissed off with Street
Fighter missing the platform you know um
you had a whole generation
where Street Fighter didn't get to the
Xbox platform
Street Fighter 5 missed the the Xbox One
and that within itself should give you
Street Fighters for everyone
mortal kombat's for everyone
um
play by the rules
Sony starts switching up the rules when
they became the dominant high-tech piece
in the space remember Microsoft and Xbox
are too high tech that's why they look
at Nintendo like their eighth generation
and then not ninth generation but the
eighth Generation
Um because they say that it's
rudimentary Tech it's inside the Box
when you are the the leader in the tech
space and then you're the market leader
not saying that their their Tech is
superior to Microsoft is comparable they
have just a differentiating things
they start dictating Pace to
all these developers and and they tell
them well we want this exclusive are you
going to tell the market leader no when
they come in there with a big enough bag
just to cover the Microsoft portion yeah
because that's basically what you're
doing
you're like all right so I'm Gonna Give
You x amount of dollars that you would
have performed on Microsoft uh estimate
you coming up with a analysis of the
forecast of the prediction of the game
and they go in there and they pay
Microsoft share
now you can skip the platform we gave
you the money here we want this
exclusive not time the exclusive we
wanted exclusive and it was going to do
that with Starfield so yeah we want we
want IO entertainment entertainment I
told people that
the one crystal diamond I told you that
they they wanted that um the the mobile
uh the group that zenge Zenga that uh
take two winner purchase yep Zinger yeah
right because but they looked at ABK as
a better you know fit like you would
because Rod Ferguson and Mikey Barra
isn't over there for no reason you start
doing the math right and then a b you
know and then King there King Works a
little bit not not better than single
but as well right if you go get that and
then you go get Sega there's a reason
why Sega went and got went out and got
the um Angry Birds uh people right
they know they next in line to get
purchased so we're gonna bolster up um
your mobile when we do get purchased so
you're just not buying Sega you also
buying them right right
yep it's strategy involved there's
conversations that are being had and
Microsoft is not going to be complacent
with being third not Phil not Satya damn
sure not Matt booty and not Sarah Bond
and any you know Aaron Greenberg all the
whole micros they want to win of course
they do absolutely it was years of
losing and pouring your sweat tears into
something they want to win
so there the end is coming but and I've
seen that list that that's crazy as hell
crazy bro but I'm happy I'm happy that
yo what's it called what's a what's a
smaller list is the companies they
didn't try to buy or at least consider
trying to buy yeah because they they won
a square yeah you don't want to put your
games in buy your ass
[Laughter]
I'm about that life I'm about that I'm
about that life so much because it shows
a willingness to compete on a level that
other people aren't willing to or they
can't Matt booty and his text said
will
spend them out of business
I love that guy
I love that guy y'all thought he was
weak every time you think somebody is
weak you'll find out he ain't that weak
dude yeah Matt didn't get in his
position Phil went out and got the
shooter you don't want the shooter I'll
go get the shooter right
you know what I go off
um Beanie Siegel 50 Cent go look up that
song that's that yeah
Booty's name
Matt the shooter booty
all right so we got two dollars from
Dragonheart baby uh hashtag peace love
life Lords and dirt we holding the line
another excuse me
high on life Dev team enjoyed Xbox third
uh Place via Game Plus
then we got a I gotta say something the
angry therapist uh Game Pass mobile next
up
I I just want to say um to Dragonheart
Yogi
I love you I owe you dinner
he does things in the background guys
that y'all have no idea and the guy
doesn't do it for anything but being
just a great guy yeah I got a two dollar
super trap from the anger therapist the
lag Jim trying to stop the show another
two dollars to try for the angry
therapist Bobby about to show her about
the short term not the long term and
we're about to get into that because
there's some stuff that you know we
could talk about when it comes to Jim
Jim Ryan in this courtroom because it's
crazy you know first thing let's go over
to dark griggity dirt tell me what you
think about this giant list of studios
and if you had the list you could read a
couple of them and see your highlights
for you I didn't have it up but hey man
I remember seeing Sony on there I don't
remember seeing screenings
yeah it's just going to show you that um
when Xbox made a decision yo we are
going to compete we're going to be
aggressive we're tired of of PlayStation
doing what they want to do in the
industry
um you know because of the position Xbox
was in they couldn't get certain things
marketing Deals they don't get many
marketing deals PlayStation gets all the
marketing deals and you know this this
case has opened a lot of stuff exposed a
lot of information we really wouldn't
know
um I remember hearing Sarah Bond say the
marketing deals
there was sometimes Xbox couldn't even
mention Call of Duty except for on Xbox
website or something like that and I'm
like damn
they weren't playing so Xbox had to get
aggressive too Destiny they couldn't
even mention yeah also Hogwarts Legacy
right those are three games in
particular where they cannot mention it
anywhere outside of Xbox own website and
I said wow that's that's crazy so it's
at the point where Xbox said okay okay
you you guys you guys are already
winning but now you're trying to prevent
us from competing at a level we're going
to compete I do want to bring up the
Super Chat I'm going to go ahead and
read the one before just to get to it uh
P lump from two dollar super track Hold
the Line Dirt I took your model POS
we got five dollar Super Chat from Derek
Margaret I don't know man if I butchered
it we moving right past that though that
list oh no the Dirk mcgirt Dirk mcgurk
there you go you gotta think dirt for
that because I wasn't going to try uh
that list made public might get Studios
to call Phil and see about being
purchased it's a buyer's market an Xbox
won't be left doubt that's interesting
and he's 100 right on that absolutely
well a lot of people are upset that they
didn't get the call yeah I mean it was
like damn why they ain't call us
hey yo hey yo Natalie that's what I
always say right you know when the play
says it for them boys talk about organic
growth and all that stuff I I use an
analogy I say look if if if you're
homeless right and you need a house ASAP
but you coming to some money would you
have a house built from the ground up or
would you go purchase a home because now
you're now you're homeless now right you
need you need right you will go purchase
at home right so anybody with common
sense anybody with common sense Force so
these guys we know Xbox needed Studios
they need IP no IPS they need the games
they needed things for Xbox game pass
and you know their first party so these
guys are that's not organic growth and I
Believe come on now stop it they had to
get content ASAP I say this
people jobs are on the line yeah all
right they don't have enough time to sit
there and wait for uh uh Studios to ramp
up and make games
see what somebody is making see what
they have in the cooker and then you go
over there and you'll be like all right
um Let's Make a Deal get the company get
this that in the third and you know
those games are that close to being
released right so you know how long ago
did they announce Starfield before
Starfield was uh you know ready to be
released I think it was like well four
or five years yeah it was 2018 I believe
right so yeah those those years that it
was okay now we purchased them that's
closer to release yeah absolutely and
Phil and and and Todd how it is really
cool so Todd's telling Phil about this
amazing game that he's working on and
all the stuff and it's going to change
the way that like you know like how
Skyrim was and and how Fallout is and
doing all these things and it's amazing
it's the world is going to be bananas
and you can get to do this and you get
to do this and this is I I'm making my
my greatest work
and you like man that's dope man it's
gonna be when everybody join you smiling
then you find out that this dude trying
to do this again right oh hell no not
gonna happen man nah we already saw how
uh Skyrim and Oblivion in these games
and Fallout changed the industry
it changed how you looked at Western
RPGs and made them able to compete with
the the final fantasies and the personas
and and sagotens and all these other
Japanese RPGs the ease Wise book one and
two and and stuff like that you know
Dragon
um Dragon Quest
he Todd
single-handedly
pushed us into that Arena
Phil wasn't gonna let that game go right
I like that and it's gonna be exclusive
because you've been doing dirty business
for a long time you're not gonna get it
and y'all
still to this day don't believe it oh
it's gonna happen so you think you think
that this trial
is gonna get that game freed to y'all so
does Jim
Johnson
he's uh kind of roasting my knowledge I
don't think he understood my analogy I'm
not saying Xbox is homeless dude I'm
saying Xbox needed games Xbox needed
content as soon as possible they don't
have the luxury to wait for 25 Studios
to build games from the ground up at the
same time they they have a studio that
was built from the ground up and look
how long it's it's taking them to
release the game even show the game
so for people to say oh you know yeah
y'all they this is an organic growth
it's BS
I don't care I don't care if they go out
and buy Street Fighter right now
I I don't care it's an Xbox game I don't
care if they went out and brought Street
Fighters if they brought Capcom today
and brought Capcom two-day and on the
box the next box is shipping out it says
Microsoft uh Studios uh Capcom deliver
Street Fighter that is an Xbox game and
you're gonna claim it and I don't give a
damn how you feel Max all right so yes
and I hope they make it exclusive I hope
they shut off your surface
so here is the list of the studios that
Microsoft was going to potentially Buy
well they had this meeting it's not like
they were going to buy which is so he's
individual Developers
uh actually let me just go ahead and
share this screen because let's all see
it uh get gather round everybody uh you
know we're gonna yeah don't treat it
like a Sony email let everybody see it
yeah goodness bro that's everybody in
energy ain't it he said who's outside
the world all right I can't share it
like that because uh it stops them from
seeing uh from seeing us but what I'll
do so everyone can see everything is I'm
going to
show them email it to you like Jim did
because he don't know how to CC anything
yeah
your man pissed points he see him son
and they don't know how to how to uh you
know make things redacted either I see
that was dope that was dope
boy Chris young boy
all right so here's the list you know
what we're gonna do is I'm gonna first
off I'm gonna I'm gonna send you guys
this link so you can bring it up on your
oh it's just a black screen bruh yeah
well it is
so here's the list uh I send it to you
guys on the on Zoom okay all right so if
you look at this we got 11 bit Studio 4A
games as the people that make the Metro
games asbo Studio obviously we know who
those are Avalanche Studio Behavior
interactive Blackbird interactive blue
uh blooper team uh let's go to the ones
I know I'm not going to read through all
these I don't know half of these Bungie
CD projekt Red
deck 13.
is devolver digital line yes
from software's on here when all those
uh jokes is coming out that oh Microsoft
is buying that and I heard this all
those guys was right right
all those guys that y'all was clowning
on talk about all his information is
always wrong he is right as hell yeah
people can Fly level five IO interactive
house Marquee
uh we got we got a bunch of different
ones here man the whole industry yeah
let's go to the Publishers real quick
505 games which you they probably own a
bunch of the games that uh that 4A makes
you got devolver digital whole Focus
home interactive media Indie exchange
raw Fury Sega and team 17. team 17 and
like that's pretty much the whole if
they would have bought just two of those
that's like the entire Indie industry
almost
yeah
so what what do you guys feel about this
list man I'm curious I love it too man
I love it I'm I'm
I want that like like you know I saw
this one this one pony crying online
right and he talked about Microsoft is
gonna destroy my game and I've been a
gamer for 38 years and you know they're
gonna destroy it and holiday destroy it
by putting out Pittsburgh games or
whatever the hell and I see guys shaking
their fists ah how that Gran Turismo
treating you
you know ah
like but King uh shut up man you just
like it when the dude that you like is
beating you up you like him you know I I
want I want the dude I like to beat you
up
so now I'm down oh man I'm down for that
yo my rug Ally needs more games
all right so let me let me look through
let me get these super chats real quick
first off shout out to Seth 100 80
people in the chat right now hit that
like button you guys look at the shirt I
got I saw a couple people comment on it
is a Demon Slayer I do have the shirt I
I'm sorry to get like a crazy amount of
anime shirts it's ridiculous like like
you see I I have nothing but IOP shirts
like three dress shirts and nothing else
but anime shirts like all that weird is
IOP yeah so uh two dollar super truck
from Alvin
Sony Cod marketing ends this year 2024
Call of Duty equals Xbox I was going to
address that five dollars from Jay
rumpert Bert or whatever did you all see
the Call of Duty accounted for almost
half of Sony's Revenue that'll change if
this still goes through and that's
exactly why they trying to stop him find
out the super guy from Spartan six
one the trivia of gaming in the house
Xbox is on its way to the show the
casual gamers they uh what they can do X
attic dirt and King all you guys are
awesome appreciated man appreciate it we
got a member chat from Sofa King he's
been a member for three months
appreciate the support man hey yo King
and addict and dirt pour one out for our
tax dollars Jokers got smoked today rest
in peace FTC two dollar super shot from
Cowboy Miss Broach who's next Phil
everybody's next yeah ain't nobody's
safe bruh he Candyman
all right so let's back it up a little
bit all right so I think we we know
what's going on there Microsoft I'd be
curious to see who actually was
approached approached you know what I'm
saying like who actually they were
talking to Bundy we heard they was
actually talking about I keep confirm I
could confirm they were talking about
you yeah yeah they was taught but Bungie
was talking that stupidness talking
about Marathon being for the streets
yeah
you know
you got a chance to see
the reason why they didn't get them now
you see yeah you can see yeah first of
all you for the streets second of all
the amount of money that um
Destiny commands the overhead he said
was too much you outpace your worth like
you aren't worth
that much money
right because you outpaced the worth so
the three billion they gotta look at it
yeah because I know people are like oh
they sold for three billion that's
that's that was kind of cheap it was
kind of cheap be honest with you right
um but we we don't know what billions is
like I've never seen a billion in my
bank account but um
but three billion
and and you'll see how everybody else is
selling you know like that's that's kind
of cheap for Bungie
Bungie is gonna outpace that three
billion within the next five to six
years
okay so Marathon has to hit
right if Marathon doesn't hit they Roi
is going to be at a loss and you might
see Bungie and and Sony separate
hmm it's going to be a if if Marathon
does not become a smash runaway hit from
the beginning and the destiny Community
doesn't flock over the marathon and they
don't get that retainer ship and um in a
fan base
you might see Sony in them split ways
because then
the the the the juicing worth the
squeeze it's not worth it yeah and they
and Sony would have already gotten
everything that they needed out of
Bungie is the expertise expertise right
game of games of service service up and
running so right now during this period
of time they're having them oversee why
this is why you ain't see factions right
they go check out this game go check out
this game go see if this game is up to
Snuff what would you change so they're
gonna milk them until pause until they
can get everything they get out of it
and then if Marathon doesn't hit don't
be surprised if you don't see a
separation of the ways right from those
two companies because Bungie costs too
much she's she's she's high priced like
Chinese is crazy and and King monzi has
a history of uh calling and quits on on
their significant other right yeah if
Microsoft activation we out if you don't
you don't you don't you don't take it
out you don't do what you're supposed to
do like she dream about that she ain't
sticking around
crazy
yeah man and I feel you know obviously
we don't know but I know you guys heard
some things but it just seen the Xbox
was like nah you ain't you ain't even
work for all that no you ain't you ain't
worth all that the first person the
first people they went to was Microsoft
yeah yeah they would have been there if
if after seeing that list
you know Phil was in the mode of buying
and it made the perfect sense for them
to go to Microsoft
but obviously if they just looked at it
and there after dealing with a chick
you know
what her do's and don'ts are right and
you understand it so if you're going
back to a relationship that you was
already in you look at what made you
separate from the beginning
and he was like nah man I see all that
same stuff cropping up again I'm good
boo love you man we had some good times
remember it is that yeah I can go into
the photo album and look at our wedding
date that Halo baby it was great we had
three good years boo-boo all right now
go on with yourself don't don't do me a
favor baby don't get out of here
these member chats before we move on to
the main event of the evening
we got a two dollars uh two member chat
from Alvin he's been a member for 11
months he's almost there that for that
year King
uh Sony first party only counts for 15
of their revenue somebody been lying
out there Jim been lying bro
remember telling the truth
[Music]
um Warzone Mobile isn't even out yet so
you know Sony doesn't want another
successful mobile under Microsoft they
won't see a dime of that
facts so
for those of you that know we are
about to that ftc's right now they're
going to war with Microsoft over this
acquisition there's been a lot of back
and forth what I want from you guys
is out uh you know dirt said he has a
couple of his quotes I'm pretty sure did
you say you found a couple of his quotes
yeah yeah so we're going to go to dirt
first he's going to break it down some
of these quotes and then we're going to
talk about this because it's it King
this is the definition of salt like so
dirt break it down first
uh
you know I love when one of Microsoft
lawyers
asked Jim Ryan um
you know because Jim Wright he you know
like he was acting real
I don't know I don't know what's the
word like what's the adjective to
describe how he was active but when she
asked him so Jim if if
if you were running Xbox
would you make Activision Blizzard games
exclusive
and Jim Ryan said that's a hypothetical
question
I'll choose not to answer that right
there tells you all you need to know
that right there tells me the answer is
yes
he he was out here crying about what
Microsoft is doing
um
and when she asks that question now now
Jim Ryan knows he's under oath even
though he's not in the building he's
under oath that's a hypothetical
question I I'll choose not to answer it
I plead the fifth that's pretty much
what he's saying it's pretty
it's pretty um then he also said that um
you know that email that came out and
what Jim Ryan said
that game pass uh I'm sorry that Call of
Duty played like Microsoft my activism
blizzard is not about Call of Duty
exclusivity yep
he said it's in the documents email
clear as they said he had he said we'll
be okay I'm I'm paraphrased here because
I don't know why I thought it had exact
quote but he said we'll be okay it's
it's okay more than okay yeah we would
be more than okay it's not about
exclusivity it's immobile they'll be
fine
so what happened you know what I love
about this dirt if you if you if you go
and listen to this how many
um this dude you would think this dude's
kid smooth saying um all the time like
like constantly
um
um and then there's one time the lawyer
asked him a question and he took so long
to answer that the lawyer re-asked him
the same question because he thought he
fell asleep no because what it is his
lawyer is his lawyer is telling him what
he should say so that's why there's that
that thing going on between the two and
it's just it's crazy
yeah and we say this right quick before
you go King but the one that I loved was
uh when um Jim Ryan said that
PlayStation first party games only
account for 15 of sieh's profits that's
right but hey King but they told me it's
about them bangers I actually had a who
told you I have a you know who told me
that
Jimmy seated now Jim Duffy didn't say
that they ain't enough I actually have
hey King I actually have a receipt of a
PlayStation fan boy we were talking on
Twitter and he told me
you're stupid dirt PlayStation
exclusives make PlayStation all the
money Call of Duty means nothing I still
have that receipt I'm not gonna say who
it was but I have that receiver
to me
so yeah man um
there's just a few things I had wrote
down that interest me but there's plenty
plenty more
no no King why now you said that you
know why Jim changed his tune because
initially he was like yo this is not
about Call of Duty being exclusive this
is a playful mobile for Microsoft what
what made him all of a sudden start
crying throughout the year let me set
the scene okay you know um Phil and
Bobby was talking Bobby is talking about
what was going on with his situation and
it was like um then it came to agreement
yo the board is down for the sale
yo let's let's get jimin on this you
know because you know um we know how the
revenue share go with Jim and
how the structure is we got to just go
reassure Jim That Ain't Nothing Gonna
Change on his side
you know Jim got there and um Gemma
weasel Jimmy weasel all right don't
don't get it messed up Jim Jim the dude
DM your girl
a straight sucker
all right you know not a stand-up dude
at all because he stood in these dude's
face and um and let me tell you I'm
gonna show you I'm gonna give you I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you the
timeline and y'all tell me if if he is
sucker or not
decide because I could see a sucker from
a mile away don't tell me a sucker no
sucker no real recognize real he looking
mighty unfamiliar um
so you know they finished the
conversation and they they all say can
they good he told you in the um email
that he had the better part of the day
with Phil
and Bobby
he go home he go to sleep he wake up
here in Brazil
hmm
and then Phil got to find out you trying
to block the deal you just agreed we
were good like right I offered you this
the third now is going to be there
because he told you he had no fear of
Call of Duty going anywhere why why
would you say that unless somebody told
you it wasn't
um
somebody told you now we're honor the
same deal that you got would do you know
we good don't worry about that why would
he tell you that it's not that play that
play that you're looking at the bigger
play is something else he's doing
something else
and they got enough cash to do it
so he went home and he went to sleep and
he realized those contracts was up this
year
um
all right so no more would you be
telling people uh Call of Duty is on
your box plays best on your body no no
no the rhetoric is going to change this
year right Duty will be in game pass
this year
what's up
Buckle it's up
you went home and realized yo we
Spider-Man got Spider-Man is ready
man we ain't gonna make no money they're
my father
there's only Spider-Man
oh man hell no we gotta stop this
dealing block the deal
I know I agreed but I'm not with it no
more that's right it was consensual but
it's now it's not it's something else
it's not milk
yo
sucker moves yeah it's like it's like
that what's that song it's like help the
bear oh yeah
it's it's it's just realizing
that this dude is not made from that
stuff right he doesn't care about you he
don't play video games right not at all
let's just keep it real somebody gonna
say you don't play video games too shut
up I work
um
I ain't a multi-millionaire either
because I was I'll be at home all day
[Laughter]
but I'm gonna tell you man this this
dude
don't play video games
he killed off some of your most
important European and Consolidated
those
um European Sony games right consoles
um
say um Sonia Japan
he closed that up
he moved the stronghold over to Europe
he's a money man if you look at the text
the text told you the email show you
that he's about monetizing and getting
every ounce of money that he can get out
of the fan base
and that's not wrong in business and
that's exactly what you're supposed to
do but when you have somebody in charge
you want somebody in charge that
actually cares
about the tradition of the consoles
the games
single player
over the shoulder story driven games is
the way of the dinosaur
Phil told you that those games aren't
really sustainable in in producing those
are conversations that they had together
Phil told you with his words
but still is producing single player
games with story driven narrative
your boy Jim showing you with actions
cutting back on single player games or
the narratives and going with more games
of service absolutely look with your
eyes don't be fooled by the past
Sean is gone
he loved tradition
when Sean left so did their exit from E3
look at it back flute man Sean was there
that was the last one he was there thank
you you gotta understand what you're
seeing here
you get a pissport show in a month that
is supposed to celebrate video games
Nintendo kept tradition Nintendo's last
show that was a nine for me
Microsoft show was a 9.5
and it would have been attended if they
would have showed some uh combat from uh
from this girl you know
hillbilly you gotta check it out and see
it for what it is bro and and I know
you're sitting there saying that you're
bot and you're this and you're that yeah
I'm a realist too as well
I paid my 500 and I see where it's going
I don't need a a a clone of what
Microsoft is doing I got Sony for what
Sony does and I thought that Sony would
continue to do what they do but under
Jim's leadership Jim showed me that he's
all about that Almighty dollar and all
company is supposed to be but don't lose
your identity chasing a buck your mother
always told you before
all money ain't good money son right and
always have your integrity and if your
mother didn't tell you that your father
should have and if they didn't tell you
I'm telling you now all money ain't good
money so don't chase that dollar down
losing yourself in the process because
you may look back
and don't know who the hell you are
anymore when you don't know who you are
nobody else is going to be around you
because you're gonna lose your friends
you're gonna lose your family you're
gonna lose everything don't chase a buck
thinking that buck is the end-all be-all
and I'm seeing Sony do that and I don't
like what I'm seeing that's why Sony's
unfamiliar to me
you get speaking facts I'll go here
first off and shout out to almost 900
people in the chat you know hit that
like button guys let's get that up man
uh find out from Michael Mooney
this deal is about Microsoft's Target of
500 billion Revenue by 2030. yep then we
got a five dollar subscribe from the
angry therapist MD Sony and Jim are down
bad yeah I appreciating all the support
you guys hit that like button man hit
that like hit the like
buttons up in here man
I was gonna say if anything Jim looked
like really it felt like in a way Jim
never expected it to go this far where
he would have to show up that's how we
that's a great way to put it at it
that's how you sound like damn
I'm really testifying in court we here
now I thought y'all said I just snitch
and go
I I that's how he was acting that's
exactly how he was acting I personally
felt like the way this went is at first
he knew they didn't think there was a
slight chat they didn't think there was
a chance they could get it canceled uh
but then they kept making their
statements and they noticed how much
things were going their way
and then it went from not only just
trying to get consolidation
now we're on full-blown let's get this
deal blocked right and then after enough
of that done
and when the ftc's like we'll see you in
court Microsoft and Microsoft's like uh
my witness is Jim Ryan
I don't know who called him as a witness
probably the FTC but Jim was like it's
like that one moment where they look
around who me I I didn't say nothing
this whole I've been I've been innocent
I haven't said nothing and then Jim gets
up there he's like she was literally
asking him questions and then almost
every time that statemented well at the
time I thought that at the time I
thought this at the time I believed that
and then there was one time where she
tricked him she was like
uh do you do you believe that Microsoft
is hurting themselves by putting
by not putting Call of Duty uh on on by
putting Call of Duty on PlayStation at
this deal goes through
and you could tell he didn't want to
answer that he said there's so many
things he said hypothetically
and then and then apparently like
there's some Emo or something or
something that related to like Jim Ryan
would do that she asked him do you would
you do that
and he's like he pretty much was like I
don't want to answer that like
it because it's just like I think this
whole time he's been going through
and he never thought he would be in a
courtroom to that degree because
Court like obviously we call it PR talk
you know these Executives get up they
talk about stuff uh most of the time
it's not true or you know they have to
go back on it that works in PR and on on
Twitter and on blogs but that doesn't
work in a courtroom
because you you're gonna plagiarize
yourself so he had to be honest about
things and who knows if he was 100
honest because at that point like
he was saying some off the wall stuff on
Twitter try to back track some of it in
the courtroom
and he he pretty much just came out
every time she kept asking him the same
question like five different ways
because it's like no you're going to
tell me why you think this is bad for
gaming stop saying this stop saying that
tell me why you think this deal is bad
for gaming and what's funny is he he
ignored all those those questions yeah
what what I like is
his statement is what if uh Microsoft
ships an inferior product right
um you know in devs had to come out and
tell you no man we don't do none of that
right from respawn yep right you have a
response hey come on now chill out with
that
people treat you
how they've been taught to you know
treat people
assume things
when they have done things
like have y'all ever been in a situation
where you're not cheating and the girl
keeps saying you cheating you cheating
you just find out that she was the one
cheating yep and it was a projection
thing so what if Microsoft ships me uh
inferior product y'all remember what
game did they send the team over to go
uh get that game finished uh Sony send
the team over wasn't it um uh Dead Space
was it dead space or something like that
oh the cluster protocol are you talking
about let's do a protocol there we go
yeah
wasn't Callisto protocol running
horrible on Xbox it was abysmal
initially when it first launched it like
it wasn't even a reflection in the
mirror on the Xbox version so what do
you see version two is running so what
does that mean that means that they send
a team over there like I want y'all to
listen to me and don't say that yo can
you get your tenfold hat on no I got my
binoculars on bro I see you coming a
mile away pause
foreign
I know for a fact that you
've done things
so you assume people are like you
you can't assume somebody is nice if
you're not a nice person
in your head everybody evil
so if you even entered me you believe
that that person is evil you can't
believe that he's nice
no he not he's not something he hide
some you ever hear people say that why
because you're hiding something right
thought processes he believes that
Microsoft will do that so that's why
when they ask someone to stand
what would you do
would you give it to Microsoft
jimin is Hard One to say hell no [__]
and boy you will never see again I
thought I can't wait I melted down to
make a run out of it
[Laughter]
no he's like no I don't want to answer
that I like how the Lord said but you're
not allowed not to answer that you know
you know remember I told people on
Sunday on IOP
Jim gonna get up there and be like I
plead the fifth
because that right there will
incriminate me and put me in a bad
position no he pretty much he pretty
much went up there and answered
everything but didn't answer everything
at the same time like they they lead
shout out to Mr Lee
instrument analysis of a market that
I've ever seen in my whole life the
wrong information you talk about you
told the judge I didn't even read the
dossier on the FTC but I want to
reference to dossier she said what the
one you didn't read
shout out to the judge right
seeing the mockery for what it is I
think y'all was gonna go in there and
run rings around people that people are
stupid they do this for a living bro nah
man you're not getting away with this
one we don't build the mouse it's about
to be ring a ding time I'm about to go
buy some champagne on Friday
we bout to drink I got my cigars right
here Sunday's gonna be crazy next Sunday
is gonna be intense three Sunday hours
and what's funny is just show up on
Sunday because it's my birthday birthday
and I'm not going to go in specifics on
the guests but we have a specific guest
coming on just to team up with King in
this foolishness
and he's they've never been on the
podcast they've never been on the
podcast too
it's going to be interesting we got a
hell of a guy and I can tell you that
it's a guy because there is it a guy or
is it a girl
we gotta find out some draft from
Facebook oh uh 007 I was one of the
people who wanted Phil to go but see now
how much BS he has to deal with and
understand his frustrations big big
respect if I don't subtract from Blue I
got to rebut that I gotta rebut that
fire so you wanted to feel the dough bro
you got a Super Chat why you wanted him
to go
I need to know that and I don't care if
it's 99 cents
with the Xbox guy yeah you can't say
nothing in my channel nonsense but if we
got a five dollar Super Chat from Blue I
actually like that name would you rather
Xbox by PlayStation or have PlayStation
get thrown in the bushes and let PS uh
flounder for a while
I want I would rather Xbox buy them it'd
be like wrestling man I bought my
competition damn it
what they want a wwfwcw moment yeah
imagine imagine if like we had like a
showcase and then you just see
on the Xbox stage it says g-o-w you
think it's got a uh you think it scares
of War but then Kratos pops out and he's
like we bought PlayStation so I'm gonna
tell you this right now and I'm not
gonna lie
if they buy a PlayStation I'm a tattoo
Phil face
on my bicep
I'm not
my mother on the inside on this side
you're gonna get on this side on the
bicep you can get on the bicep get on
the bicep on the inside on the inside on
the soft tissue that hurt cause I know
it hurt every pony in the world if if he
was the boss Sony
a man I wouldn't know how to act for the
rest Twitter will explode like it would
Twitter would you you think Marcus or
whatever that dude name was having a
meltdown the other day you think
it was having a meltdown yeah the red
dragon in these dudes is having fever
fits boy it'll be over Twitter will look
Elon will have to make another Twitter
just for them
the harassment complaints is gonna go
down
[Laughter]
I'll make a video daily oh man
and the concert won't be over I'm like
damn it's opening over it was over
before it started over you see
Spider-Man swing out and you hear the
music
Spiderman no no no no no no king king
it's worse than that they make a montage
of all the Xbox figures killing all the
Playstations
and they get resurrected as Xbox figures
no no check it out it's worse than the
attic they have the E3 stage and then um
Spider-Man come down on the web right
and you're like what the hell is coming
down what's it you know how he hangs
upside down and he comes down and Phil
pops his mask and it's real gotcha [__]
man I'll be crazy bro you gotta be the
best that'll be the best I'm down for
all of that all that stuff about all of
that oh yeah
that's funny stuff man he said King
David he's been a crazy show man five
dollar super trap from the angry
therapist how about the fact uh how
about the fact Jim refused to give
Microsoft to Dev kids
I see okay look I agree on to a point
but to a point that's kind of all common
like uh you know not Microsoft you talk
about ABK if the deal goes through
yeah that's what he said the deal goes
through Greg with the two all super ff16
is now running at 60 flames
like it's on five oh 60 Flames per
second okay oh my God man we are 50 you
you guys like I know this is probably
not gonna happen we are 50 viewers away
from a thousand on an attic show I would
be Beyond thrilled if I hit one show
that does an IOP number just one we
don't got to do it ever again I don't
care if you got to pull up all the tabs
other times I don't care what you guys
Gotta Do
but some of you hate me so you'll
probably leave the stream the moment yo
yo yo let's save the the red nose South
Bronx Pitbull
[Laughter]
let me show you all this right um
shout out to somebody listening to what
I said about little man
and um I don't know your name I gotta
double check I gotta look back at the
Tweet but he uh yeah put that oh no
I like that I like that I like that
no no no no no that's the um
it's kind of interesting withdrawals
you can draw the white one like smaller
because we were making fun of it the
other time but see you the package is
different
oh man they're the same height as
somebody packing a little bit more oh if
I don't got a 10 super track from 007.
Phil was not allowed to talk openly
about the PS deals behind the scenes and
the practices that Sony doing to block
game pass those that made uh that made
to think that he does not want to
compete aggressively
I feel you guys like
I don't care one thing I will say
King will tell you every time that
something came up with the FTC I might
want to talk about it CMA I don't want
to talk about it anything
division related I don't want to talk
about it right this deal this court
proceeding
made all of that worth it
the amount of salt that has happened
because of this court proceeding it's
like it's fueling me it's like
it's like it's I don't know if you guys
seen the Avatar The Last Airbender at
the end where you know they're taking
they're taking the rashique say back and
he comes up there and he's sitting there
breathing in the wind and he's like a
fire bender hasn't felt this in a
thousand years and he's just sitting
there breathing in about to go cause
Havoc that's what I feel I'm sitting on
this mountain and I've seen an Xbox had
a fan hasn't felt this in years
and I'm just glowing man got a two
dollar subscribe from Spartan six six
months I found her in great on the grill
if you know how to grill
hey guys FTC has screwed the deal all be
done next week
showed our momentum lesson learned how
PlayStation is going to learn their
lesson to keep games from us okay hey
bye Bungie oh gee you guys are being
just too kind man like real generous
people man uh GSD getting stuff done 50
Super Chat Jim Ryan the critical feature
of the gaming console in terms of its
attractiveness to the people who make
games is the level of its install base
the kind of utility of the user base for
people who make games to monetize
against I had to like raise my voice
because uh he he made the last like caps
so I I I had a I had to pull up for that
one man that's that's the part that Jim
said and that's important I'm talking
about this deal going through
oh
I told Joe to hold the line and y'all
thought hold the line was for the uh the
Whatchamacallit you have to hold the
line had something to do with the the
show all right so I'm okay right now
it's seven to one
we're gonna end this I'm gonna do my
outros I just put a poll in the chat I
think it should be showing up any minute
man hold that line bro I want you guys
to vote in there man tell me what you
guys think is gonna happen first off
shout out to almost a thousand people
that showed up to the podcast yeah man
hit that like button on your way out I'm
gonna probably send you over there to
fame uh definitely go over there I know
some of you don't because obviously you
know you sent me over to the Jamaican
game I was at him no no I'm talking uh
well today I thought last weekend I mean
we'll see who's on right now we'll see
who's on right now
let's
let's do this redirect let's see who's
on you know
uh we got Level One gaming he's pretty
much the only person that's on
so let's go to level one yeah so we got
five dollar Super Chat from Dolan Knight
all the smoke coming from Canada or
people Final Fantasy VI
you got one from drawing TJ too like he
said uh
this is for you bro no ps6 facts
can you get um Stitch 6669 uh I don't
think that you're coming so fast yeah
I'll get it for you oh with the five
what do y'all think about the email
detailing that Microsoft could could
have locked Call of Duty as an exclusive
for just five billion but they want the
building five billion just to make a
game exclusive is ridiculous bro I'm not
doing it I would never do that I mean
nowhere in the world uh idiotic you know
why just spend the rest of the bread and
just lock it up marry them let's go you
know put that ring on it if you really
about that life and see Sony would do
that it's only got that five billion to
do that they budget for the year
you talking about big spending bro these
dudes is pulling up in limos buying out
the the bar you know they partying all
night you gotta put your mind in that
mindset they're not going in there with
with a couple of racks in a pocket just
throwing it at the chicks at the stand
now this is Floyd Mayweather money bro
start thinking that way when you start
thinking that way then you say oh man
they're different in the strip club I
hear you guys so let's go and do these
outros man so far uh let me see who's
winning on the pole I don't even need to
look at it but let's see yeah yeah I
mean you know come on man you know
hold the line is winning from 200 it's
90 to 10. dirt what's going on man what
what kind of content you got going
through we gotta know and what's funny
is I see this I got this this thing
a bookmarker yeah I found a there's a
poster with this too I didn't get it
though but I'm gonna start like what I
plan on doing is I plan on having those
posters on the wall and just switching
them out from time to time oh that's
what's up your stuff man yeah man yeah I
actually just dropped the video man you
know I do the console war stuff so I'm
making fun of the the homie uh Marlon
gaming man he had a meltdown live on
here so I'm talking about it so check my
latest video guys oh man so you know
having a good time you know have um
stop by and subscribe to my channel if
you were Xbox fan we have a lot of fun
over there we can get messy but we try
not to be so messy
but yeah man let me put the link in the
description I mean I'm sorry in the um
chat
check out my latest video guys
yeah and definitely um you know pull up
man pull up uh I I feel like there's a
lot of people that don't get like a lot
of shine that's why I'm very open with
people activating that raid feature
because I feel like I'm not I don't have
the access to raid as many people as I
like you know I saw people in the chat
here's the thing like if I'm raving
something unless it's our own content I
want you to go to someone that I
generally feel can use the growth that's
why I go to level one gaming Jamaican
gaming like they're grinding and
grinding and I feel like they deserve
that shine I wish they would it was
easier I wish you could rate anyone you
want to because then I would just start
right out what what I would like to do
king is get to the point where we watch
like a minute of someone's stream and if
we get the thumbs up we just send
everyone over there you know what I'm
saying yeah all right so I appreciate
everyone coming through man king what's
going on man what what can we expect
this Sunday on IOP
you can expect it being my birthday
you expect it being July 2nd my birthday
uh you can see me uh turn it up and
hopefully Friday this uh deal gets
passed and everything gets done
because it's supposed to be the 29th
supposed to be the end of this stuff
yeah that's tomorrow I'll be on dcx
Friday night 9 P.M
go check that out it's on YouTube it's
statue stuff so if you're curious about
these statues and you want to know why I
told you don't uh pre-order that
Spider-Man PVC crap go buy the digital
version and just go pick up a statue
like that Spider-Man 2018 that I got
right here
um for the same amount of money go do
that so you can have an investment so if
you need to sell it because you can't
sell them to that PVC plastic crap that
you got on your show throw it away get a
real Statue look at this one man
oh that looks nice that looks nice see
he's heavy into Demon Slayer right now
and because I added my animation uh
growth has been stunted so I must watch
my uh Attack on Titan so I can finish it
up so I can get to uh where he's at with
Demon Slayer and all this other stuff
um RNR with the Lord's uh attic and I uh
Eric is severely overworked
so we're in the midst of revising it uh
it's going to be myself and another host
uh we're trying to work out the
logistics on that and that will be
behind our patreon so you know this move
this Friday I'm gonna go see Indiana
Jones
and uh we'll be talking about that we'll
also be giving out synopsis on the flash
and so far this year in general when it
comes to movies itself so all the movies
that we saw so far that's you know uh
Spider-Man across the spider verse and
uh the Fast and the Furious 10 and uh
Super Mario all that stuff we're going
to give a synopsis of what we feel this
year has done and what we have coming uh
for the rest of the year as far as
Aquaman and all that other great stuff
so we're going to be talking about that
but IOP this Sunday is a Sunday that you
do not want to miss I mean you do not
want to miss IOP if you thought I was
having fun here you do not want to miss
IOP on Sunday addict told me to pull up
I'm sorry I pulled up a little bit late
brother but um you know Wednesday's a
little bit difficult but I can make uh
difficult scene possible so I definitely
was going to be here and I definitely
was going to meet up with my Ray Choice
twin
um
dirt dirt says the stuff that I can't
say and I want to say and then when he
say POS I'm in my house giggling and
laughing like a school girl so I love
your content bro thank you bro I
appreciate you it's like I said I
appreciate it for coming through like I
said I'm sending you over there to fame
entertainment and level one game level
one game I'm being on Fame show next
week man yeah next week you're gonna be
on okay back to back next week back to
back
what we can do is I'll bring a guest all
next week and you can leave a little
early so you have time to get what you
need done yeah yep all right but I
appreciate for coming through we're
gonna send you over there to fame look I
get it uh I would go over there just
type something in the chat show some
love even if you can't stay man just
seeing the numbers and the likes over
there would make them their day way
better go over there in droves and tell
them that the attic show sent you an IOP
sent you and I appreciate every one of
you going here and how you way out hit
that like button man hit that like
button man so we talk to you guys later
see